uh on the layups the last couple of  games have been a little rough there i  mean  was tonight was go bear a factor there  it seemed like you guys were getting  there and  he wasn't affecting as many shots and  he's just you're just missing him uh i  think he was in in people's heads like  just he wasn't even blocking shots for a  long day i think he was just people was  just going to the rim and it was just  like oh they got rude over  and i'm saying i'm telling him like  right he's  the same as anybody else but like to me  the best ripper target in the league is  porzingis like any time i go against  percentages i don't get no layups like  you know i'm saying  so like  i don't get why we couldn't finish on  ridico bird but  don't put no fear in my heart  yeah i don't know why